[Aplausos]
i
bien
alguien de ustedes alguna vez se quebró
jugando a las escondidas
jugando al fútbol haciendo willy con la
bicicleta o pintando un techo
ah
[Música]
cuando yo era chiquita en rafaela tenía
algunos amigos que les gustaba mirar un
programa que se llamaba titanes en el
ring algunos los imitaban y más de uno
aparecía luego en clase con una fractura
a mí me encantaba andar en bicicleta
pero no no me quebré lo que me pasó es
que un día cuando volvía de andar en
bicicleta llego a casa y me esperaba una
sorpresa me habían comprado un jueguito
de química con todas las indicaciones de
lo que no tenía que mezclar
y no saben las cosas que sí y mezcle
escondido en el fondo del patio de mi
casa haciendo salir humo de todos los
colores y exponiendo me a situaciones
peligrosas pero ya estaba hecho me
gustaba investigar lo que pasaba es que
tenía que aprender a hacerlo bien
hacerlo mejor ya no ponerme a
situaciones indeseables en nuestro grupo
de trabajo de investigación
trabajamos en medicina regenerativa o
sea aplicando técnicas de ingeniería de
tejidos que es lo que pretende que
cuando hay una faltante de tejido tratar
de colocar una serie de materiales que
de alguna manera luego se transformen en
este tejido reparando la lesión
estos materiales deben promover entonces
la división de células la síntesis de
sustancias extrañas y específicas no es
tan sencillo elegir la matriz entonces
me di cuenta que tenía que aprender que
tenía que estudiar y que esto iba a ser
una historia colaborativa para
profundizar en nuestros trabajos de
investigación nos asociamos con grupos
de la fundación jiménez díaz de madrid
del instituto bio jorge de valladolid
minas era el riberao preto la facultad o
en todo logía de tucumán viajes visitas
laborales pasantías llamadas de internet
señales de humo todo es válido cuando se
considera que el trabajo en conjunto es
imprescindible la idea de hacer
investigación se fue fortaleciendo en el
trabajo en conjunto
no le pasa a las matrices con los
tejidos las matrices tienen que
integrarse al tejido tienen que
integrarse respetando el entorno para
que para promover la división celular y
para que se forme el tejido óseo de
nuevo tal cual como lo queremos
en estos años hemos trabajado con
muchísimas matrices con muchos tipos de
matrices es más algunas las hemos
utilizado como transportadoras de otras
moléculas que favorecen la formación del
hueso en el sitio exacto de la lesión a
eso nosotros los llamamos delivery
tal cual porque porque haciendo delivery
logramos que las matrices lleven las
moléculas que favorecen la formación del
hueso al lugar preciso de la lesión y no
que sean desparramando por todo el
cuerpo y generando situaciones
indeseables
por el otro lado nos interesan
ultimamente unas matrices muy
particulares que tienen unas señales
químicas estas señales químicas son como
secuencias de reconocimiento que por un
lado permiten que las células que
nosotros deseábamos empiecen a dividirse
y proliferar y por el otro lado que
otras células se encarguen de degradar
la matriz de irla destruyendo estas
matrices son biodegradables su función
es temporal
un equipo de trabajo los roles no
necesariamente son estancos a veces las
funciones deben ser intercambiables
en estos dos últimos años también
trabajamos con una sustancia con una
matriz que su mujer un tanto insólito
porque insólito porque se comporta al
revés de la gelatina cuando está frío es
líquido y cuando llega a temperatura
corporal califica además es un derivado
de una proteína natural de la elastina
que promueve elasticidad a los tejidos y
eso lo hace para nosotros muy
interesante
hemos colocado con infecciones heladas
en el sitio de la de huesos dañados a
este gel y observamos una reparación muy
muy importante estudiamos por tomografía
tridimensional la reparación y así lo
hemos observado además estos geles son
biocompatibles que quiere decir que se
integran que respetan el entorno que no
generan ningún tipo de rechazo
sumado a esto estudiamos por microscopía
bajo microscopio el tejido que estaba
allí en el sitio de la lesión y
notablemente vimos que se había formado
tejido mineralizado como es el tejido
del hueso y con células similares a la
del hueso nosotros estamos convencidos
que en poco tiempo ya va a haber para la
utilización en seres humanos matrices
que reparen lesiones óseas esto ya no es
ciencia ficción cuando yo en algún
momento pensé en trabajar en este tema
muchos me dijeron déjalo para viajar las
estrellas para el cine esta ciencia
ficción como vemos el cine lo considero
un arte mayor me alentó aún a seguir
trabajando en este tema porque está
convencida que en toda actividad de
investigación tiene que haber una cuota
de arte pero ojo no olvidemos lo
importante la vida es una red de
interacciones
en el cuerpo como entre los seres vivos
si nosotros vamos en contra de esa
impronta nunca podremos ser exitosos ni
tener soluciones satisfactorias a
nuestros problemas las matrices
trabajando en conjunto colaboran con la
vida promoviendo la formación de tejido
nuevo nosotros trabajando en equipo
estamos tratando de colaborar con la
vida
[Aplausos]
[Música]